- Welcome back, y'all.
I'm hanging out with Elle King.
Once again, give it up.
(audience cheering)
So May is Asian-American
and Pacific Islander Heritage Month,
which celebrates the rich history
and cultural heritage for
tens of millions of Americans.
A group of authors are working
to get more children's books
with AAPI stories and characters
into school libraries,
'cause that's important.
And here to talk about it,
please welcome authors
Yobe Qiu and Serena Li.
Everybody give it up.
(audience cheering)
So, meet Elle.
Everybody meet everybody.
So, Yobe, this idea came
from a very unexpected place.
Tell everybody when y'all thought of it.
- I was watching Oscars that one night
like all of America was
and I was completely overjoyed by the wind
of "Everything Everywhere All at Once".
The excellent--
(audience clapping)
Yeah, yeah.
But the light bulb went off
for me when Michelle Yeoh said,
"I want all the little
girls that look like me
to know what's possible and dream big".
And then I thought I have to do something
to extend that representation.
I called up my friend Serena
and our two other author friends
and I was like, do you wanna join me
on this campaign where we
fundraise to get hundreds of books
and send them to school districts,
five different states in America.
And we hopped on a Zoom call
and the rest was history.
But we got so excited
that we named--
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
But we got so excited,
we actually named the campaign
"Asian American Books
Everywhere All at Once".
- Oh, I love that.
And 'cause that's where the idea spring.
That's amazing.
So, to both of you,
you say, no matter where you're from,
no one has the same story.
So explain what that means to you.
- Yeah, exactly.
Well even though Yobe
and I both identify as Asian Americans,
but our story couldn't
be any more different.
I, myself, I was born in China
and moved to the States at age of 14.
Without speaking a nick of English.
Right and--
- That's hard.
- It was really hard.
- At fourteen as well.
Fourteen's already a hard age, right?
Yeah.
- Yeah. In fact I learned
English through songs.
And Kelly, your song, "Miss Independent".
- Oh.
- Held a whole other level of meaning.
(audience cheering)
So, so yeah.
As a first generation immigrant,
living in a place without much diversity,
I actually have neighbors
and classmates that would ask,
"Hey do Asians actually speak Asian?"
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So now that I have a daughter of my own
and I always long to pass on my heritage
and language to her,
and that's how I started
my publishing business
called "Duck Duck Books".
And I made multilingual kids
books with my mother tongue,
like Cantonese and Mandarin.
- [Kelly] Yeah, beautiful.
- Yeah. We have very similar experiences
but also very different experiences.
I was so lucky, I grew up in New York City
in the middle of--
- Very diverse.
- Very diverse, lower
East side and Chinatown
and where diversity was absolutely
embraced and celebrated.
And then I went to become a teacher
and I was trying to get books
that featured Asian children
and families and cultures,
but there just weren't many.
And I decided the best
time to write a book
was to write something
for Lunar New Year time,
because I was teaching
a lesson at that time.
I was creating my own
material, like all teachers do.
And then I went on to research a ton
of how different Asian
communities celebrate
our Lunar New Year.
And I learned so much, Kelly.
I've learned about how the Thai community,
how the Vietnamese community,
how the Indian community,
Chinese and Korean community
celebrate this holiday.
And throughout this whole process,
what I was most proud of is,
we are living in a great time,
where representation is
really exciting for us now,
but I just feel like there just isn't
that enough books for children.
- Absolutely.
My kids are fortunate
cause I didn't grow up,
and I don't know how you grew up,
but I didn't grow up around a lot
of diversity in half of my childhood,
and it was one of those things,
that I look at my kids
and they celebrate all
these different holidays
that I'm learning about as an adult.
- Right.
- Like, you know, 'cause
I never was taught
when I was a kid.
- Right.
- But they're so exposed
because they live in a city
that kind of is like how you grew up.
It's so diverse.
But like I didn't grow up with that.
Like, knowing a lot
about different cultures
and their, you know, their
holidays or anything like that.
Did you grow up like that?
- Halfway.
Ohio? Not so much.
My grandmother's from Manila
and when she moved to
America she became a teacher
and so I had a really big
extended Filipino family
in San Francisco, that
was a really massive part
of my upbringing.
So, this is really
beautiful because I don't,
since my grandmother's passed on,
I don't know what ways to show my son part
of his culture and heritage.
And so this is really beautiful
that you guys are making these.
- [Yobe] Thank you.
- It's really important. That's awesome.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, it's super important.
(audience clapping)
Well, Serena and Yobe,
since it's AAPI month,
what are some great books that
you recommend for parents?
- Yes.
So I absolutely adore one
of the authors called Tracy Guan.
She's actually right here in the audience.
Hi, Tracy.
- Oh, what's up?
- Yes.
(audience clapping)
So, Tracy is actually one of us four
that are doing this campaign together
and she has a book called
"Lunchtime with Samnang",
which talks about this
Cambodian boy, you know,
and his adventure during lunchtime,
where he learns more about his heritage
as he was tasting these yummy,
you know, Cambodian dishes.
- Yeah.
- And if you have older children,
middle school or high school,
I recommend a book by Vincent Yee.
That's another one of our authors.
Say Hi, Vincent.
- What's up, Vincent?
(audience clapping)
I really like that series
because it shows Asian Americans
that they can be superheroes
and I think everyone
should have the opportunity
to see themselves as superheroes
in stories that they read
and TVs that they watch.
- Yeah.
Especially kids growing up.
That's so important.
Well, Scholastic shares
your mission of making sure
that all children are being
able to see themselves
and their stories reflected in the books
that they're reading,
which is why they're excited
to donate a thousand books written
by AAPI authors and
featuring AAPI characters.
- So excited.
- Because, like I said, it's important
for everyone to see themselves,
but it's also important for
every kid to see other kids
that aren't like them. You know?
- Absolutely.
- Right.
That's just as important. I think.